so as she learned let's talk about all
this crossing we're doing whether it's
split time or same time a good habit in
anything you doing is any pattern any
way you can hold it learn to hold it so
don't just cross and come back cross and
see if you can be comfortable in the
crossed position with either hand on top
so you can cross put your right hand on
top so you can get your nice straight
planes or cross and keep your left hand
on top and again see if you can keep
your plants you also want to do this
split time and if you can learn through
the split time and at first don't worry
it's definitely going to be all fluffy
it will lots of stuff you'll be learning
will be floppy at first it's normal so
you can start you can even cross your
arms first and just try to and if it's
like all floppy floppy don't worry next
week it'll be better just to get the
process started
see if you can get a forward you know
split time going at least a little bit
either Harmon top just a little bit and
then when you do your crossing so you
can cross it and do a couple and come
back and then the other way and do a few
spins and come back and you'll start
getting because our body you know we
don't typically do a lot like this so
it's you know it's a bit of psyche as a
kid when you do this thing you're the
witch finger but that's like that you
know it'll take your brain a little bit
to figure it out but it will you'll have
you'll enjoy walking it all start to
work so cross your arms you can start
same time try to get in your split time
and then every time you practice you'll
be a little more comfortable with it and
then you'll be amazed at how comfortable
how comfortable it is to slide in and
out of that position and then you're to
beat we will feel really smooth and the
other two beat we will feel really
smooth and these will feel really
controlled and you can start progressing
higher and lower out fire
in close one high one low
you're always exploring high low where
you can reach fast slow all of it it's
like good text so enjoy that and